[Music]
we continue our celebration of hispanic
heritage month by introducing you to a
group of women who are just really
shaking up traditional mexican music
that's right they call themselves
mariachis
or mermaids lourdes duarte shows us how
they are inspiring a new generation of
latinas
[Music]
it takes practice
[Music]
and a lot of heart
[Music]
to make the kind of music that has
elevated all 11 of these women to become
one of the most sought after mariachi
bands in the midwest i remember having
this idea
um i think i was like around 17. but it
wasn't until three years ago that ibet
herrera helped launch mariachi sirenas
if you're wondering what that means
sirenas means mermaids but no matter
what language you speak they've made a
splash on a traditionally male dominated
industry half of the girls have
full-time jobs and then the other half
are in college and i have one high
schooler so between sneakers and book
bags every week is packed with gigs and
if we're lucky we get mondays off but it
hasn't been easy they had to first win
the support of their peers i would get a
lot of but you guys are just women why
are you guys charging that much and then
the public who was used to the deeper
tones of all male mariachi performers
now it's more of oh you guys are
actually busy that's that's interesting
to know that you guys actually have work
and while they're the only all-female
mariachi group in chicago women have
contributed to this style of music for
generations there have been female
mariachiras there have been female
mariachi groups
a female mariachi group actually went to
vietnam to play for the troops in the
uso show
a lot has changed since then just like
our artrages in itself it's not the
original cut that's just a straight
skirt cut we have more of a mermaid
skirt do your hair however you're
feeling if you want to have it up have
it up if you want to have it down have
it down just you know make sure it's you
we want to make sure that we feel
comfortable with ourselves while we're
performing and not just putting on a
literal mask to fit
this idea of what traditional mariachi
woman should look like la sirenas have
for the most part stuck to tradition
keeping music lyrics with just slight
adjustments to the sound it's hard
especially for the trumpets because
their range
they can only go so high and once you
switch it to a female key
there it's kind of rearranging their
instrumentations or other knows there
yeah that's fun though yes mermaids yes
mermaids are known for pushing the
envelope a bit legend has it they
sometimes lure sailors to danger but in
this case la cedena's main goal is to
sing at one of chicago's most iconic
landmarks we want to perform in melania
park
yeah it's our goal
[Music]